so I'm going to try something a little
different today what I'm going to be
doing is giving you a list of my top
five things that make me feel nostalgic
now most of these things are very
personal to me so please don't comment
saying what about this and what about
that because this is my list of things
that I remember from my childhood that
make me go like the good old days number
five the Super Nintendo is really the
first system that I actually played and
just absolutely love my friends and I
would play this system for hours on end
games like Donkey Kong Country right
here we would play for hours and hours
and hours till we memorized all the
music and all the different little
places where you had to jump and of
course there's those formal be creature
things that always pop out and kill you
when you're ten minutes and it'll anyons
and restart is horrible other than that
fantastic game now I can remember
playing mini Super Nintendo games or for
some reason Donkey Kong Country and
Super Mario World stand out the most to
me as being very memorable and very
nostalgic for me now and I think about
that this game at the very similar
gameplay as the NES Mario except for the
fact that the graphics were better the
lands were a little bit harder and a lot
of the controls were a lot better than
the NES version still though when I
think about the opening credits music I
just get this little feeling like oh I
remember that it's just great number
four somebody won't tell me the world is
gonna roll me yes I was one of those
children who sat by the radio and hoped
that my favorite time would come on with
the cassette tape so I could record it
nowadays we all download from the
internet but back then I recorded things
on a cassette tape from the radio
because that was what cool kids did back
then
I love bands like Sugar Ray and smash
mouth and Third Eye Blind and I would
just listen to the songs over and over
again on the radio and they never seem
to get old to me like songs today get
old I miss those kind of songs and there
by me of the good minds the birth three
old Nickelodeon that's right the
Nickelodeon of the 90s before it became
the Nickelodeon that it unfortunately is
today shows like angry beavers cat dog
KaBlam are you afraid of the dark
all that Kenan and Kel Doug Rugrats
Rocko's Modern Life and my personal
favorite Hey Arnold these shows just
seem to have more heart more feeling
they seem like they were actually trying
to make quality entertainment not just
make the same dumb shows over and over
and over again like they do today and
she was like hey Arnold meant something
there was morals there was a message
they were actually trying to reach young
people's minds it wasn't just mindless
entertainment like it is today
but I do love spongebob and you get
extra props if you remember this little
guy I kind of you might want to stay
tuned for details
number two few things make me happier
than remembering the times of playing
Nintendo 64 all night and being so tired
that I was tired throughout the entire
day of school I loved all the classics
like Super Mario 64 and Zelda Ocarina of
Time and Goldeneye of course but there
was one game that I thought was very
underrated that not too many people
played as much as they should have I
felt and that was jet force Gemini a
game that I absolutely loved I played
this game for hours on end my friends
and I would get together and talk about
which weapons that we get which new
characters did we get how far are we are
we close to the end how many tribals
that we collect it was just an
incredible game and in all honesty my
favorite video game score of all time by
Robin bean Lynne please looking up it
came out the same time Donkey Kong 64
came out and so it kind of got
overshadowed by that and I feel that if
you still are into playing in 64 if
you've never played Jeff worst time I
definitely pick it up once again extra
props if you are a Nintendo Power
subscriber and got this VHS in the mail
No
from the deepest reaches of space some
darkness approaching the ultimate enemy
has arrived I have a bad feeling about
all this
there's single-purpose destroy our world
blades play they sting I once took an
online quiz that asked me what my
favorite part of school was and I
replied the fact that I could run home
from it to watch tsunami seriously
tsunami is my childhood so many
excellent show Powerpuff Girls Samurai
Jack outlaw star Gundam Wing Dragon Ball
Z and yeah you know you watch Sailor
Moon at least once or twice put along
with that some of the greatest techno
beats ever and you've got one of the
greatest programming blocks of all time
on top of that tsunami has one of the
largest fan followings for a programming
block ever there are people on the
internet begging for it to come back in
some way or shape or form on Cartoon
Network so I'm just gonna stop talking
and allow you to appreciate the
nostalgia this guy turns black
wickedly from my slow look at that steam
I felt the power like this
are you not a year